- [Voiceover] In a
survey of a random sample
of 1,500 residents aged
25 years or older from
a particular county,
399 residents had a
bachelor's degree or higher.
If the entire county had 635,000 residents
aged 25 years or older,
approximately how many county residents
could be expected to have a
bachelor's degree or higher?
All right, so we have this random sample.
We randomly sampled 1500 folks,
aged 25 years or older.
We find out that 399 of them
have a bachelor's degree or higher.
So of our sample, 399/1500ths
have a bachelor's degree.
Now the entire county has 635,000.
635,000 residents
aged 25 years or older.
So when they're saying approximately,
so we're gonna estimate in here.
How many residents could be expected?
Well, since this was a random sample,
you would expect that the same
fraction of the random sample
that that would be
approximately the same fraction
of the general population
aged 25 years or older,
that would have a
bachelor's degree or higher.
So we could just take this fraction
and multiply it times
the entire population
to have a good estimate of,
or good expectation for the total number
of folks with a bachelor's
degree or higher.
So we could just multiply this.
Now, there's two things going on.
We really just want to
get an approximation,
and the good thing is is we have
multiple choices right over here.
And these are fairly spread out,
so we could round some
of these numbers here
to simplify this a little bit.
So this is going to be
approximately the same thing.
399 is awfully close to 400,
so it's gonna be
approximately 400 over 1500
times 635,000.
635,000.
And that's approximately
the same thing as let's see,
four over 15.
I divide the numerator
and denominator by 100
times 635,000.
635,000.
Let's see, I could multiply
all of this out if I want,
but this quantity right over here,
that's gonna be...
So this is what we're, if I could just,
we could figure what that is,
but once again, we're just approximating.
So this is gonna be greater than.
If I just made this at 600,000,
and I'm just gonna do that.
Just 'cause it's kinda close to 635,000,
and 15 goes into 600,000 nicely.
So whatever quantity this is,
this is going to be greater
than four times 600,000
over 15.
And once again, I went
to 600,000 just to make
my math a little bit easier,
and because 15 goes into
600,000 nice and easy.
'Cause 15 goes into 60 four times.
So if you divide the numerator
and the denominator by 15,
this becomes a one and
then this becomes 4,000.
Or sorry, 40,000.
Instead of 600,000, you're at 40,000.
So this boils down to,
maybe I'll cross out this.
This is 40,000.
So it's gonna be four times 40,000,
which is 160,000.
So our approximation's gonna
be greater than 160,000,
and there's only one choice here
that is greater than 160,000.
And if you were to multiply this out,
you would get even closer to
169,000.